(smacks)
- Ow.
(laughing)
That's enough BDSM in the kitchen.
Let's make some Matzo balls.
(upbeat music)
(creaking)
Hey everyone I'm Aaron.
- And I'm Leslie.
- We've been friends for a long time.
But despite that,
we haven't really cooked
for each other a lot,
which is weird because we
both care about food a lot.
- Oh yeah.
I grew up eating a lot
of Cantonese cooking
because my parents are
from southern China.
- And I am Jewish, so I grew
up eating a lot of Jewish food.
So I thought it might
be cool if we went out,
got some groceries, cooked
some cute meals for each other,
and maybe in the process
learn a little bit
about each other's cultures.
- I think that sounds like a plan.
- Are you ready?
- I'm so ready.
(Chinese music)
You ready to get some Chinese groceries?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- We are in the Chinese supermarket.
We're about to get all the ingredients
for my ketchup shrimp.
(whooshing)
(popping)
(beeping)
- Awesome, thank you.
So we got the ingredients
for the Chinese dishes
that Leslie's gonna be making
and now we just gotta get the food
for the Jewish dishes that I'm gonna make.
(record scratches)
Okay but wait, hold up.
What do I mean when I say, "Jewish food."
Traditionally, observant Jews keep kosher,
which means they can
only eat certain things.
The meals I'm making
today are Jewish dishes,
but I'm not using kosher ingredients.
They're not being cooked
in a kosher kitchen,
so they're not kosher.
They are however, delicious.
(upbeat Chinese music)
So I'm making something
that's gonna be like very
classic, very standard.
Potato latkes, which normally
you eat during Hanukkah,
but you can also eat them at any time.
And another thing I'm gonna
make is Matzo ball soup,
which was something that
I ate every Friday night,
every Shabbat.
- I'm going to be making
ketchup fried shrimp.
So my dad made this for me
all the time growing up,
but I haven't had it in a while actually.
- I'm a little nervous
'cause I've never actually
made Matzo ball soup.
- I haven't made ketchup fried shrimp.
(record scratches)
(crickets chirping)
- Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
(happy piano music)
What is your favorite memory
involving Matzo ball soup?
- Growing up, my family
wasn't super religious,
but we did pretty consistently
recognize Shabbat,
a time of the week where
you slow down and you rest.
Pretty much every Shabbat dinner
had to have Matzo ball soup.
It was like a staple, it was like a given.
(happy piano music)
(lid clatters)
Latke dance, makin' latkes.
- Why'd you pick latkes?
- Because latkes are something
you traditionally eat during Hanukkah.
Growing up as a kid, some
of my favorite memories
are from Hanukkah.
Just being with your
family and getting presents
and eating good food.
And it's such a fun holiday.
- Just do it to taste.
That's how my parents, my grandma.
- This is actually (beeps) delicious.
Oh my (beeps) God.
Just ketchup and some tomato paste
and soy sauce.
- Right?
- But it's so good.
- So you can just go ahead
and cut off the heads.
(popping)
cut it.
(gasps)
- Oh.
- Oh my.
So dramatic.
- Oh no.
Shrimpy, I'm so sorry.
(sighs)
- We're gonna put all of
the ginger into the pan.
My dad is from Guangzhou,
China, which is a port city.
It's really close to the ocean.
I just remember sitting down at dinner
and then getting so
excited when I found out
that he made ketchup fried shrimp.
I feel so lucky to have
grown up with his cooking
'cause he got that training in China
and now when he makes dinner for us,
he makes six or seven dishes.
It's ridiculous.
(upbeat music)
- Leslie, this looks amazing.
- I know, ready to eat it?
- Yeah.
(mysterious music)
(slurping)
- This is really good.
- The Matzo balls are a little dense.
If it had been my mom, they'd
probably be a little fluffier.
Ta-da.
- [Leslie And Arron] Mm-mm.
- Okay this just tastes like Judaism.
- I thought this would taste so weird
with applesauce but it works.
- The sweetness of the applesauce,
and the tanginess of the sour cream,
and the salty, oily, potato-y,
carby-ness of the latke.
It just makes sense.
(gasps)
- Ta-da.
Let's dig in.
- This is actually really good.
- I'm so happy I got to
introduce you to this new dish.
- I think I'm eating a piece
of shell from the shrimp,
but I don't even care
'cause it's still good.
- I kinda just wanna finish this TBH.
It was just really nice
getting to try foods
that you grew up with.
- China's such a huge country
and there's so many different
regions and ethnic groups
and it was nice to learn
about where specifically
your family came from
and the kinds of things
that you grew up with.
- Aaron?
- Yeah?
- I'm so happy you're my friend.
(sighs)
- Leslie, I'm happy you're my friend.
I think we make a good team.
- I agree.
(groans)
(happy music)
(whooshing)
(creaking)